ja wir haben jetzt gerade die situation
in bremerhaven gehabt
man merkt finde ich an dieser stelle
auch wir haben jetzt wir sagen über zwei
jahre lang in einer ausnahmesituation
gelebt also bewohner hat als thema alles
dominiert und jetzt dominiert natürlich
der ukraine krieg alles auch zu sich man
hat ja das gefühl alle anderen sorgen
und probleme sind ein bisschen kleiner
im verhältnis zu seinem elend das da
stattfindet aber die ganze gesellschaft
mit all ihren problemen ihrem leid ihrem
kummer ihren schwierigkeiten und ihren
verbrechen lebt halt weiter und das sind
83 millionen menschen die für die findet
leben statt jeden tag und leider eben
auch immer mal wieder diese ausnahme
situation das ist ja sozusagen fast in
dem rhythmus von zehn jahren also
passieren diese dinge also dass das sehr
schulmassaker von erfurt winnenden es
war 2009 jetzt haben wir den aktuellen
fall was all diesen sachen gemeinsam ist
das war ja auch beim tollen beim
massaker in den usa wurde ist natürlich
das waffenrecht alles immer noch
schlimmer aber auch bei dem
schrecklichen massaker in norwegen in
utoya es sind taten von männern es sind
häufig einzelgänger
sie sind oft im netz in der schwierigen
weise unterwegs und
im unglücklichsten fall haben sie im
zugang zu waffen den sie so nicht haben
sollten das ist bei uns schon ja sehr
viel besser geregelt als es etwa in usa
ist aber trotzdem ist natürlich mit den
sportwaffen immer noch ein gewaltiges
risiko in der gesellschaft das heißt man
müsste schon gucken kann man nicht doch
den zugang zu sportwaffen so beschränken
dass die nur im verein greift wir sind
da sagen die sportvereine immer sofort
das geht nicht gut ich sehe auch die
probleme aber dass sie zuhause rumliegen
und dann der waffenschrank nicht
ordentlich gesichert ist dass es halt
auch eine katastrophe und wir kommen
halt das wäre sozusagen mein wichtigster
punkt politisch kann man nur begrenzt
sozusagen gegen diese art von
katastrophen und schickt also unglücke
tun
aber eltern müssen natürlich einen
wachen blick auf ihre kinder haben und
ich weiß wie schwer das ist gerade mit
der netznutzung also wenn ein junge von
19 im netz unterwegs ist das kriegt ja
dann der gelernte bibliothekarin oder so
möglicherweise wirklich nicht mit oder
eine englischlehrerin oder was weiß ich
aber man muss ein gesprächs verhältnis
zu seinen kindern haben und gerade in
diesem fall nun wirklich zu den jungs
und dann muss man auch gucken also was
ist mit frei beweglichen waffen in
meinem haushalt das kann sehr familie
niemand abnehmen also politik kann
helfen ist es gut dass wir jetzt diese
sicherheitstrainings schulen haben dass
die also wissen wie sie sich jetzt
verhalten sollen wenn das war ja wohl
heute auch der fall also tür zu also die
nicht die klassen dann auch zum teil
sind die räume von außen nicht mehr zu
öffnen das ist alles gut aber die letzte
verantwortung und das letzte aufpassen
das ist in der familie zu hause es ist
ja eigentlich wirklich schrecklich dass
wir diese sicherheitstrainings in
schulen haben ja das ist ja das ist ja
zeigt die absurdität dieser verhältnisse
dass wir unseren kindern beibringen
müssen was man machen muss wenn ein
amokläufer
kommt ja und ich denke auch dass es
wichtig ist was die eltern was die
eltern machen die eine große
verantwortung aber ich sehe die
wanderung auch bei den schulen die
schulen ist die lebenswirklichkeit
dieser kinder und wir wissen auch dass
solche themen wie mobbing und ein
problematisches selbstwertgefühl gerade
junge männer dazu hin leitet zu
attentätern zu werden und dass dieses
mobbing findet in der schule statt und
in social netzwerken und da brauchen wir
da auch da ausgebildete pädagogen die
das abfangen können ja und die da
schneller angebote haben weil ich weiss
nicht den eltern das jetzt auch noch
aufzuladen es ist ein bisschen viel aber
natürlich sind die eltern auch da in der
pflicht dazu schauen also irgend jemand
ist selber schuld dann sind sie eltern
sind sie sozialarbeiter haben wir nicht
genügend gemacht im vorfeld und so
weiter ich glaube wir leben in
deutschland schon ganz gut eben auch
wegen deren wegen der vernünftigen
waffen politik die wir hier haben und
jetzt wieder nach verschärfung von
gesetzen zur ruhe man
ja aber wir werden das allgemeine
lebensrisiko
nicht auf null bringen ich glaube dass
unsere gesellschaft immer so denkt alba
meines lebens gesagt nein natürlich
nicht das ist schon richtig in der
schule muss man aufpassen
der jugendrichter muss auch aufpassen
und viele institutionen müssen aufpassen
in einer kirche und und und und es wird
ja auch ganz viel aufgepasst aber ich
glaube nicht dass mal wird aufgepasst ja
in dem ein junger schule ganz viele
sozialarbeiter gucken können
die mitschüler gucken auch es ist das
thema ist der in der gesellschaft drin
es ist sensibilisiert und so weiter
gleichwohl werden wir nicht jeden fall
in den kommenden zehn jahren verhindern
ich habe nach er vor da hat es auch
tausende von diskussionen gegeben wie
werden wir alles verhindern ich glaube
wir stehen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch sehr gut da trotzdem es
ist richtig dass man diskutiert
ist es wichtig jetzt zu besprechen sind
die regeln richtig sind wir einer
richtigen balance zwischen
zu akzeptieren das ist ein lebensrisiko
gibt zu was kann man alles noch machen
was machen andere länder wie stehen wir
im vergleich also ich finde das ist
schon eine wichtige diskussion dass
heute die dass dieser vorfall
bremerhaven das ist schrecklich da in
eine frau schwer verletzt worden ja wir
sollten das diskutieren ohne panik wie
sie herr müller ist schon gesagt haben
aber mit den fakten und vor allem also
ich denke auch dass das strikte
waffenrecht in deutschland und frau
gesehen total recht es sind häufig die
sportwaffen weil irgendwann der familie
sportschütze ist und die jugendlichen
die gerade in diesen schwierigen phasen
sind und sich dann sozusagen auch fasste
also in diese richtung entwickeln viel
net eventuell unterwegs sind damit einer
neuen kontakt kommen die dürfen auf gar
keinen fall zugang zu waffen haben und
mir geht es auch nicht um schuld
eigentlich also dass das das macht dann
gleich den ganzen kontext und negative
also ich glaube ein punkt ist sicher
richtig da haben sie völlig recht also
die die schulen müssen sicher beim
mobbing also noch genauer hingucken das
ist einfach ein unangenehmes thema da
hat man sofort als mit irgendwelchen
eltern hat man dann immer ärger und als
lehrer ist das nicht dankbar nicht also
am ende hatten alle als lehrer wenn man
da eingegriffen hat insofern kann ich
das auch verstehen aber da glaube ich
eine höhere sensibilität gerade noch mal
was da im internet veranstaltet wird
auch wirklich an backstage und und
fürchterlichen sachen also dass das ist
wichtig ich würde nicht schuld sagen
sondern chance ich glaube die eltern
haben dann doch die beste chance zu
wissen was mit ihrem kind so los ist und
man muss halt sprechen sprechen sprechen
das ist wirklich eine anforderung und da
kann man immer sagen zu müde zu viel
arbeit zu langer tag viele stunden ja
auch in der einrichtung die die jungen
leute oder die kinder sowieso und dann
die etwas älteren jugendlichen auch aber
trotzdem wer soll denn miteinander
sprechen können wenn nicht eltern und
kinder und deswegen also ich glaube es
ist nicht waren sich originell als
vorschlag aber man muss es einfach immer
wieder sagen es gibt zb in einem roman
der amerikanischen autorin lionel
shriver heißt die let's talk about kevin
das ist ein schöner roman wo die autorin
sehr also sehr empfehlenswert einfach
auch vielleicht für eltern die sich
meine gibt auch auf deutsch ich weiß es
nicht genau den deutschen titel aber die
eltern die sich vielleicht ein bisschen
sorgen machen was ist mit meinem kind
weil da kann man einfach mal so ein
bisschen die muster sind da in
literarischer form verarbeitet da kann
man vielleicht auch ein bisschen gucken
wie komme ich an also wie komme ich an
wieder ins gespräch oder brauchen wir
wasser und roller in schulen nein nein
entschuldigen sie
der taschenkontrollen dies und jenes an
begleichen können denn wahr machen es
gegebenenfalls vor der schule oder
sonstwo
also was wir auf keinen fall brauchen
irgendwelche verschärfungen des klimas
und verschärfung von gesetzen das
brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen ein
besseres aufpassen vielleicht hier und
da und weil es natürlich wichtig ist wir
müssen gucken wenn jemand tatsächlich
gemobbt wird dann müssen andere
institutionen eingreifen die eltern
schaffen es manchmal einfach nicht aber
er dies schaffen so etwas nennen
wirklich mobbing oft der grund es war ja
dann lassen wir für amokläufe also
soweit ich informiert bin
waren ja oft nicht der faktor mobbing
auslöser sondern sondern andere dinge
und ich finde ich glaube was sie gesagt
haben frau sein film ist auch wichtig
hin zu gucken bei eltern pädagogen und
so weiter und vorzeichen also soziale
netzwerke oft werden diese sachen ja
angekündigt dass man da genau hinguckt
und ja die ersten waren zeichen wahr
nimmt es wird ja viel verhindert schon
weil die leute hinkommen aber eine sache
frage ich mich schon warum laufen nur
jungs amok
warum sind 90 prozent aller gewalttäter
bei mir männlich ja warum ja weil sie
irgendwie sich anders irgendwie raus
drücken müssen
ich habe in meinem leben wollte er eine
einzige und ich lebe schon 30 jahre alt
jugendstrafrecht ja nur eine einzige
dame junge damen natürlich weg spielen
müssen sonst waren es immer männer ja
warum man dann möchten wichtig tun wenn
er müssen auf irgendeine art stark sein
die wollen sich irgendwie behaupten der
frau auch gegenüber awp ich bin stark
ich weiß es nicht das liegt in den genen
denke ich
nicht
wo es auch darum geht leute abzuziehen
man braucht geld für klamotten und so
weiter ich habe er menschen die klauen
irgendwelche klamotten damit sie schön
sein aber beim aufwand tatsächlich ist
das tatsächlich anders also ja da sind
für viele leute viele jugendliche haben
keine freunde werden gemobbt problem mit
dem selbstwertgefühl
das haben jungs und mädchen oder er aber
die gehen damit tatsächlich anders nur
ein mädchen internalisieren dass mehr
verletzen sie ihr selber diepresse.com
depression angststörungen ritzen jungs
externalisierung ist er und was muss man
damit machen das ist das eigentlich de
facto toxische männlichkeit toxic
masculine et ja und das liegt auch daran
dass ich denke dass man beiden männer
und frauen da oder jungs und mädchen
therapie anbieten muss und ich glaube
ich noch mehr in den rollenbildern von
männern zu sagen wenn die therapie gehe
ich nicht ja das kann ich wieder das
kann ihn nie haben also insofern ist es
glaube ich ein grundlegender unterschied
zwischen zwischen den geschlechtern hier
aber es wird dadurch verstärkt dass ich
glaube ein jugendlicher anders breivik
er dahinter nicht auf den auf den
vorgang von frau rasch wieder zu
sprechen dass es anders motiviert ist
also dass jungs an das ist ja eigentlich
schon bei den eltern liegt bei wenn ich
jetzt hier zu hören ist es ja schon so
vielleicht müssen wir die einfach anders
erziehen die jungs ja also es ist sicher
ein komplexes ist sich ein komplexes
problem sind ja häufig die opfer dieser
dieser gewalt hatten auch überwiegend
mädchen und frauen also da ist häufig
dann auch noch so ein aspekt von
frustriert sein weil man vielleicht
keine freundin hat war man bei den
mädels da nicht landen kann mit seinem
einzelgängertum ganz bestimmt muss man
die jungs in der erziehung noch viel
mehr zum reden bringen als die mädchen
mädchen reden ja also frauen lösen
probleme sozusagen häufig über
kommunikation bei männern gibt es halt
diese blöde alte gewalt option noch
nicht und insofern wird die dann auch
gezogen wenn man sozusagen ausser sich
geriet und in der psychischen aussichten
wollte wollte es kann sein dass estland
na ja und wir diskutieren ja auch die
ganze zeit ich habe natürlich eine sehr
weibliche erziehung also sehr sehr viele
alleinerziehende sozusagen wohl
natürlich die kinder dann doch immer
noch traditionell bei der mutter sind
kindergärtnerin grundschullehrerinnen
insgesamt die lehrerschaft hat sich auch
verweichlicht in den letzten jahrzehnten
das wird ja manchmal auch diskutiert
also sozusagen bräuchten die jungs eher
positive männliche vorbilder wo ein
bisschen gerangelt dann im prinzip auch
mal okay ist aber eben mann massakriert
nicht nicht das ist das sind natürlich
nie direkte zusammenhänge das ist eine
direkte kausalität aber nochmal drüber
nachzudenken wie erziehen wir jungs in
dieser gesellschaft das ist glaube ich
dringend angesagt